Ils sont des millions à se poser cette question chaque année..
Mais personne n'a encore réussi à obtenir une réponse..
Qui a la plus grosse ?
*Musique ''Qui veut gagner des millions''*
Alors 50:50 ou l'avis du public ?
Aujourd'hui on est sur ''Name That Animal Penis''
Trouve à quel animal appartient ce pénis en français.
Ça a l'air très extremement amusant
Et si je suis le seul à penser ça
Et beh cette vidéo aura 3 vues c'est pas grave
''OH MOINS MOI JE SAURAI QUI A LA PLUS GROSSE PUTAIN''
Les pénis des animaux sont de toutes formes et tailles..
Il est temps de mettre vos connaissances à l'épreuve et de voir si vous pouvez trouver à quel animal appartient ce pénis.
START GAME !
*rire* ''What''
Un rat ? Un chépakoi ? Un armadillo ou un lapin ?
''C'est pas l'pènis d'un lapin ça ?''
Noon c'étais un rat putain..
C'est pas grave c'est..
?????
Un serpent , un dauphin , une balaine ou euuh ''une seal''
Euuuuuh
Un dauphin ?
Putaiin !
Naaan c'tait une otariie
Ehhhh (dégout)
Un rat ? Un.. Euh nan c'pas l'rat
Le Snake (serpent)
Nan y'a des poils
Le lama ? Ou le Furret ?
Le furret ?
OUI !
Oh putain qu-est-ce que c'est qu'ça
Euh... plus de pixels steuplé mon gars
J'sais plus si c'est un pénis ou...
Une équerre ! J'ai rien trouvé de mieux...
C'est un "squirrel" !
Noooooon !!! C'était un merecat, un suricate...
Quoi ?
Attends, c'est carrément un bouchon en liège, lui son pénis
Un renard, un éléphant, un chat ou un "Bull"
C'est pas un renard ?
OH
Attends mec, un renard.. !
AHH (rire)
C'est quoi ?! C'est répugnant mec !
Une "seal"
Ah la.. Mais what la photo improbable
Mon dieu c'est quoi ça mec ?
Comment tu veux que je sache ? Un coquillage.. ?
Mais c'est quoi ça ?! Une fleur ?
Même pas le temps de voir. Oh put***, qu'est ce que c'est que ça ?
On dirait une bande de cire mon gars
Les filles vous vous épilez avec des pénis de.. Éléphant, machin, truc.. COCHON
OUIIII
Attends, par rapport à sa taille, y'a carrément un gros zizi ce cochon
Oh mec.. Je ne sais même pas où est le pénis ! C'est une tortue, c'est une tortue !
Totalement une tortue posée. J'ai toujours pas vu où était le pénis mais j'ai vu que c'était une tortue
Oh put***: un panda, un rhinocéros, un gecco, un kangourou
Put*** on dirait un put*** de serpent son pénis
Kangourou ?
OUIII
5/10 put***. C'est nul.
Franchement peux.. mpieux.. peux mieux.. pieux mieux faire.
"Play again"
(rire)
Mec c'est quoi ? Un "Squid" ?
Oh non un "Orca" ! Mais oui bien sûr mec
Qu'est ce que c'est que ça ? Je ne sais même pas ce  que.. Un python ?
(rire)
Il est où ? Nan mais là.. Il est où ? Expliquez moi. Komodo Dragon !
Oh la truc improbable mon gars !
Ah mais ça c'est le pénis de.. Squeezie. Nan une grenouille
(rire)
j'ai reconnu ses petites cuisses de mer** là
Hein, qu'on a tant disséqué au collège
Euuuuh.. Une antilope ?
4/10 déjà, là ça monte très très vite là.
Là je vais pas te mytho, ma prof de SVT elle serait fière de moi
Mer**. Python. J'ai cru que c'était un python sur l'image, alors qu'en faite c'était un pénis de.. fin incroyable..
Attends, abusé! C'est un rhyno ou un hippo ? Un éléphant ! WHAAAAAAAT
Nan mais les gars laissez nous plus de temps. Iguane aller hop. Voilà
Ça c'est fait, au revoir, à plus.
Alors ça, ça c'est une aile. Ou un boomerang.
Je sais pas, je sais pas. Je stresse, je sais pas.
Bah c'est juste une bite géante?
Oh putain, c'est aquatique, y'a de l'eau !
Un dauphin, un orque, un great white, un tiger...
Un great white !
OH MON DIEU !
IL A UN SABRE MON GARS !
*rires*
C'est génial !
6/10...
C'est moins génial...
Un Rat ? Un écureuil !
*rires*
Oh Put*** !
Une o... un... c'pas un chien ? Un ours noir ?
OH là là, on est chaud !
Mais ? Plus de Pixels !
Allez, un rat !
Mais plus de pixels s'te plaît mec...
C'est tellement petit qu'ils doivent zoomer comme des malades sur la photo.
Pff !
On dirait une glace à l'eau.
Mon pote.
Un buffalo.
Oh, c'est ridicule !
oooooohhhh
M********* !?
Une autruche !
Mais c'est bizarre cet animal, hein ?
C'est vicieux, c'est vilain en plus, hein.
Un lion, un tigre... Un léopard.
Put*** c'était un tigre.
4/10 ! C'est de la m**** !
Il faut qu'on fasse au moins 8 !
On se concentre ! Que la force du Pénis soit en nous.
'Fin soit avec nous, pas en nous...
C'est euh...
Voilà.
Oh mon dieu, c'est un ver de terre.
Allez, Armadillo.
Oui ! Je ???
Moi je sais, je serais capable de tirer en pensant que c'est un ver de terre qui est en train de l'infecter quoi.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ça ?
Oh là, ça, je sens la conn****... le bison ?
*exaspération*
Si vous êtes prof d'SVT, vous savez quoi faire avec vos élèves demain. Voilà.
Vous les faîtes réviser tout en s'amusant.
Ça c'est quoi ? Hippo ? Rhino ?
Hippo, je crois ?
Oui, Put***, le 10/10,
On peut l'avoir !
Ah c'est quoi cette... C'pas un Orque ?
MAIS POURQUOI ELLE LE TIENT ?
POURQUOI ELLE LE TIENT ?
Mais pourquoi lui, il l'a sorti comme ça, hors de l'eau ?
Oh non ! C'est quoi ?
C'est une main ? C'est une mitaine ?
Ce n'est pas un pénis !
Tapir, Duck, Monkey, Echidna.
Tapir.
Put*** c'était Echidna.
6. Il nous faut 10 sinon Maman nous nous laissera pas XP sur WOW ( World of Warcraft ).
Ça... c'est... une Flatworm.
BOOM !
Ça ? Hippo ou Rhino ? Hippo ou Rhino ?
Rhino.
Rhino ? Éléphant ? Éléphant ?
PUT*** !
Je serai le plus grand trouveur de pénis !
Oh put*** le piège, c'est quoi ça ?
Un papillon ? Vous foutez pas de moi !
Un éléphant ? Non. Un Rat ? Non.
A Moth ?
WHAAAAAAAT ?!
MAIS QUELLE EST CETTE CRÉATURE, MEC ?!
C'est bon, allez, on se concentre.
Oh, m**** ! La glace à l'eau, c'était qui ?
C'était qui la glace à l'eau ?
C'est le Buffalo, non ?
PUT*** !
Euh... ça c'est un...
Cheval !
Put*** c'est vrai...
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOHH !
*rires*
MAIS ON DIRAIT UN PHOQUE TOUT COURT, MON POTE !
Blue Whale ? Baleine Bleue ! Baleine Bleue !
Put*** !
Sperm Whale ! P't*** elle a Sperme dans son nom, j'aurais dû deviner que ça ne pouvait être que ce truc là
qui ait un truc aussi gros !
Oh oui c'est gratuit !
MEE****** !!
Le Canard !
Non ! J'ai trahi mes potes, les canards !
8/10...
C'est mieux que la moyenne de la classe.
Bon vu que je suis seul, c'est un peu cheaté, j'ai forcément la moyenne...
Merci, merci à tous ! Merci !
Je vais devenir professeur de sciences... et vie...
C'est génial !
Ou alors, je vais rester Youtuber, dans le doute.
Et voilà les gens, c'est la fin de cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à aimer si ça vous a plu !
C'était un peu gore, on ne va pas se mentir, c'était un p'tit peu trash
mais put***, c'était drôle. Et on sait qui a la plus grosse.
La Sperm Whale, là !
Elle nous a calmé !
C'est simple, son pénis fait ma taille.
Pour de vrai.
Je suis totalement fan des jeux complètement c*** comme ça,
où il faut deviner, où ça t'étonne, mais en plus t'apprends des choses en même temps, c'est parfait !
Soyez pas choqués, hey c'est bon hein !
Vous avez bien un zizi.
Ceux qui n'en n'ont pas, vous allez en voir un un jour.
À la très prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez-vous bien, tchao tout le monde,
PEACE !